in this video we want to talk about what
I think is going to possibly happen in
the next days and also what I expect for
today's price action okay but so far
what I see is that we've been inside
this range for quite some time then you
got abbreviation here about friends
highs and when that happens then you're
gonna visit the range laws and in most
cases you see then the breakout at the
other end of the aviation okay so that
would be a breaker to the downside and
we are targeting this potential support
here that if we check at the left of the
chart
is basically this one
that it was a strong resistance once and
we're having tested our support yet okay
so that's what I see now this one is a
song where we could be thinking about
um running some Longs okay but for that
what I would like to say see that that
we come here we hold this on
consolidable support then you know you
can go higher towards this target again
range lows okay or drop hard deviation
below this support get back above it
test it a support and you have another
long trigger here
again to the range lows that's what I
see for Bitcoin at the moment I'm still
running my shot from 31 400 took some
profit at 30k to be honest well I'm
still riding part of the trade okay uh
that's what I see for Bitcoin in the
bigger picture uh tomorrow we have fomc
meeting okay but before we get into that
I'm gonna continue talking about these
significance is here because to be
honest
in this one here there is still call of
liquidity okay does that mean that we
could still see a deviation below this
range get back above
Tesla support and then long until the
mid range
uh I cannot discard this idea but I
don't say likely at the moment okay why
because we have Stills fomc tomorrow
um they are projecting at 25 basis point
hike that should be still pretty much
for Bitcoin Bitcoin is already trying to
price that in
with this drop this week okay at the
start of the week but I'm not sure guys
okay I think this is this has the
potential to continue dropping because
the dollar Index is still looking very
strong
okay we're gonna go in a minute through
the dollar Index order book and high
block Capital but of course yeah I just
don't see it lightly so I'm not gonna
bet in favor of this idea until or if
we see you know get back above here test
the support and then here I'll run along
here okay to the mid-range and I could
the short that I'm running from here
okay but until that doesn't happen
then I believe that Bitcoin is set to
continue going lower okay to this
potential Zone uh also because we have
here some liquidity pools look at these
large green candles on the left okay but
this one has been now
fully recovered but do you still have
some more here okay lower so that's what
I think I think that Bitcoin is gonna
eventually gonna go lower hey I'm gonna
go now through the other book and hablo
capital
to check if it's supporting this idea of
Bitcoin gorilla be lower or not and then
we're going to talk about what could
potentially happen today
we are now under their book I know that
could be quite confusing chat for some
of you but I want you to focus in the
red bars because in those zones is where
there is more liquidity okay based on
limit orders stop losses and
liquidations okay so if you check at
this chart
let me ask a question where do you see
more liquidity to the upside or to the
downside
of course to the long side check out
twenty eight thousand five hundred and
twenty eight thousand two hundred okay
there is quality more liquid to the
downside now you can see
that between twenty nine thousand five
hundred and twenty nine thousand three
hundred so you can see some liquidity so
could we see today a push towards that
zone before coming lower in the next
days to 28 500 and 28 200. that's what
this
and see what it says
seven days time frame liquidation heat
map and I want you to check this out
guys okay let's get this one
what do you see here
okay you see that between 28 800
um 28 650 very still qual of liquidity
so this drop
isn't done yet okay it wouldn't make
much sense to push High
and then don't come lower I think they
will eventually come to this Zone again
okay the twenty eight thousand eight
hundred twenty eight thousand seven
hundred because there is still call of
liquidity there
I don't know if you guys can see it
those yellow bars of course there is one
there is some 31k but I can only favor
those targets if tomorrow Jerome Powell
is quite dovish in his speech in the
press conference and of course if we get
back inside the earth range okay well
unless if we don't get back inside the
range
I'm not gonna favor 31k again I'm gonna
continue further lower prices because
that's what the structure in the chart
is telling me all right uh so basically
I wanted to show you this chart
just to inform you that yeah there is
still some liquidity to the downside
still
so going back to bitcoin uh we've seen
that this is still indeed some more
liquidity in this one here
okay so uh that they could leave until
tomorrow okay until f4mc so they will be
setting some kind of trap today now let
me go into the one hour time frame let's
talk now about what could potentially
happen today
to be honest with you guys usually the
day before I made your news announcement
the market is usually boring and you
know stay
unquiet and not available
check this out okay look at the volume
what do you see here do you see here
that the large green candles
have quite a lot of volume
okay so this is telling me that at least
for today I don't think that they are
planning to set price lower
okay because this is telling me that
they've said okay that's enough shorting
time to stabilize the price in this Zone
with this volume in these green candles
okay to stop all the cell impressa and
now I think that the most likely thing
is the price it stabilizes in this zone
until the new announcements comes out
tomorrow now if we see some volatility
today or if today it wasn't sorry for
alarm going on there if today wasn't the
day before the fomc so I'm expect I
would be expecting some more volatility
then I could tell you guys okay
potential three times pattern okay first
up second up now you're waiting for the
third up maybe here
okay so you have here the three types
button and then you can see a reversal
towards this one could this happen today
I'm not sure because again the day
before I made your news announcement
the market likes to be quiet and wait
until then so uh I'm not really
expecting this I don't think that today
would be a good day for day traders of
course yes if you're going to the five
minutes time frame one minute time frame
there is always some weeks or imbalances
that you can trade okay but I'm not
expecting much to be honest
the maximum thing that I we could see on
in the next 24 hours it's something like
this in my opinion
literally something like this again if
this happens to be honest I'm not gonna
lie to you this is uh
1.5 percent move okay with some leverage
uh you could take it to a five percent
to ten percent again uh no much going on
in Bitcoin if I'm honest with you guys
so be careful trade it until tomorrow
now tomorrow I'm gonna try to post a
video a bit earlier to talk about the
FMC and what we could potentially see
going on tomorrow okay so stay tuned
guys also
in just for this video I asked you if
you wanted me to post an altcoin market
update a lot of you said yes so I'll
probably post that video on the weekend
okay so you have also some content on
the weekend Monday to Friday daily
updated with Bitcoin and then at the
weekend and altcoin will update I almost
forgot to talk about the vxy okay uh
this is what we've basically been
projecting for the last few days okay
this potential deviation they can get
back inside well get back up of this a
previous support Zone okay test their
support to consider that that happened
here
okay and then since then it's been
pushing higher and in yesterday's video
we've been talking about this cup here
in the dollar index that you can see
that they are fulfilling today okay so
pretty much uh quite bullish on Google
index also with uh the news tomorrow
with a new 25 uh basis points hike
um I think they are already starting to
price that in now I lie to you because
99.8 percent of the market is expecting
the 25 basis points so I don't think
there is any doubt that I want to hike
tomorrow to be honest so I think that's
why the dollar in this has been running
since then because there is time to
price that in now if tomorrow we see we
hear Jerome Powell saying something
quite hawkish in the press conference
okay like for example
not discarding new interest rate hikes
or talking about inflation is still as a
big problem and they have still to fight
against it and that there is no going to
be Red Coach this year
if he says something like that tomorrow
if he goes through that through that
tomorrow
then
we're gonna see the LA Remix continue
going higher right so
um be careful because you know the
Bitcoin trades against the dollar so
having a bullish and a strong dollar
that's not really good news for Bitcoin
okay so that's pretty much everything
guys
I hope you are finding this content
useful and you're reading a lot from the
videos but we've opened these courses
for any of you that feel that you want
to learn the trading system in detail
step by step through different lessons
with PDFs pre-recorded videos so we've
opened these courses uh you can find
some information in the website uh
clipnumber.com and if you click here in
courses uh to be honest most of them are
fully booked okay we only have some
spaces left for September group two and
October group two dates in discount okay
because you are booking in advance so if
you're interested go through the website
gain some information and feel free to
to ask me any questions okay guys so
that's pretty much everything thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
soon